RETO MEIER: Welcome to "Build
Out," where real engineers face
off building fake products.
Today's challenge,
the smart garden.
I'm Reto Meier, the inevitable
winner, which means this is--
COLT MCANLIS: Colt
McAnlis, the only one of us
who has actually done
any real engineering.
Whose thumb is the greenest?
Find out now on "Built Out."
RETO MEIER: And Colt
lost the coin toss,
so now he has to go first.
He'll have four minutes to
describe his smart garden
solution, including one
arbitrary VP requirement.
I will then have three
minutes to respond.
COLT MCANLIS: This week,
our VP of engineering
has mandated that we use--
RETO MEIER: The Tasks API.
COLT MCANLIS: Yes, the
Google Cloud Tasks API.
RETO MEIER: Yes, the
Google Tasks API.
We know that YouTube comments
solve all known problems.
So when we're done, you get
to decide which one of us
solved the problem better by
adding a comment of your own
to our video.
COLT MCANLIS: I've got
the winning solution,
and I'm about to prove it.
Real gardeners know that
it's not a passive hobby.
It requires daily maintenance,
water, sunlight, and attention
to make sure that those plants
are growing and yielding
fruit in the optimal ways.
As such, when I think
of a smart garden,
I want something that
optimizes this process
and creates less work
for me, which means
I want an upgraded CNC machine.
The trick here is that instead
of a drill bit on the motorized
head, our smart garden is fitted
with a water spout, a UV light,
and a camera to take pictures.
We'll also hook it up
to some nutrient tanks,
so we can use that to spray
the plants with extra food.
We could replace the cutting
area with a plant bed
where the plants
are placed in trays.
Each tray has a sensor in
it to detect the moisture
and nutrient levels, as
well as the general weight.
Because as the plant grows, the
trays are going to get heavier.
Now, most DIY CNC arms are
controlled by a Raspberry Pi.
But for a smart garden,
we need something
that has easier interfaces
to internet connectivity
and sensors.
So I'd like to add an
Android Things hub, which,
besides defining the
logic on driving the arm,
can also collect sensor data
from the plant nutrient tanks
and communicate that
with the internet.
The hub also gives us
a client-side end point
to receive logic blocks that
define the behavior of the arm.
See, there's always a
default behavior client side.
But based upon the weather
data or plant information,
we'll want to push down updates
to that behavior over time.
Now, once a day, the client
will go into an analysis mode
where the arm moves around to
take photos and sensor readings
for each of the plants.
This data is then uploaded
to the cloud for analysis.
And here is the important part.
Once the content is done being
uploaded in its entirety,
we need to signal our cloud
applications to start analysis.
One way to do this would be
to set a cloud function that
fires off once a
new GCS bucket gets
new analysis sets uploaded.
But there's a problem with
that in that currently the max
duration for a cloud function
is 540 seconds, which feels
a little constrained to me.
This is where the Tasks
API comes into play.
Once the data is done uploading,
the Android Things hub
will ping an App
Engine front end,
which is responsible for pushing
requests to the Task API, which
sometime later will spin
up an App Engine instance
to handle the work.
These tasks can run
for up to 24 hours.
So plenty of time for
us to do our analysis.
Now we've got the
photos of the plants,
so we want to recognize things
like decay, bugs, fruit,
and the size of the leaves.
To do that, we're going to
train a set of TensorFlow models
for each of these scenarios
and run our pictures through it
in order to gain information
about the size, health,
and growth of each plant.
But here's the complication--
we can't get to TensorFlow
from App Engine
standard, which means
we need to switch over
to App Engine Flex
and upgrade from the
regular App Engine Tasks API
to the Cloud Tasks API.
Once the analysis
is done, the results
are then pushed to
data sort, which
it can be accessed by the admin
console, built with Polymer,
and adhere to material
design principle.
This allows our
smart garden admin
to check out the
status of everything,
and then see the trend lines
in a nice consistent manner.
Now, in the case that
something goes wrong
or an action needs to
be taken by the farmer,
we leverage Pub/Sub to send
messages to registered Android
devices for creating alerts.
Finally, the
analysis results will
be combined with local
weather, day and night cycles,
and sensor data to create and
update new behavior patterns
for the arm.
This will allow our smart garden
to optimize sunlight, watering,
and nutrients for
each unique plant
that it's responsible
for, guaranteeing
the best growth, health,
and fruit yield possible.
And that, my friends,
is a smart garden.
RETO MEIER: Not bad, not bad.
There's some good stuff there.
COLT MCANLIS: Well, are
you ready to respond, then?
RETO MEIER: Have
the Perth Wildcats
appeared in 31 consecutive
NBL finals series?
COLT MCANLIS: I don't
know and I don't care.
RETO MEIER: Of course they have,
because they're from Perth,
so they're winners.
Let's so this.
There's a lot to like about
Colt's CNC death harvester.
It's a good start, but it's
lacking in imagination.
My design sets your garden free.
We take the head off
the arm and replicate it
to plant dozens of
independent devices,
each with its own dedicated
water spout, nutrient system,
and sensor array
around our garden,
one alongside each plant,
tree, and flower pot.
We also incorporate some toys
to help with garden maintenance,
like an autonomous lawnmower.
We still need his
Android hub, which
collects sensor data
from all our devices
and connects to the internet.
But rather than
controlling a single arm,
it now monitors and controls
the device added to each plant.
The garden devices connect
to each other and the hub
using a BTLE mesh.
I'm going to take advantage of
my unique Android experience
here to add an Android app.
Now normally, the
whole system will
be driven by a cloud service,
just like Colt's design.
But I want a local
peer-to-peer override
for modifying the schedule,
toggling the sprinklers.
The Android app is also how we
add new plants to the garden.
You take a photo of the plant
you want to add, and then
use TensorFlow to recognize it.
Now I have to admit, most of
Colt's client implementation
is pretty solid.
But again, he's
lacking imagination.
Colt's system performs
an analysis once a day.
Let's expand that to
continuously monitor
each plant.
We'll use Pub/Sub
to reliably deliver
the real-time readings from
every sensor up to [? run. ?]
Next, I'll upgrade
the Android hub
to use the Firebase
real-time database as a way
to store the watering and
fertilizing schedule that'll
sync between the hub server
and Android app, while still
working offline.
While we're doing databases,
we'll add data [INAUDIBLE]
[? to run ?] and populate it
with the care instructions
for every plant in the world.
We can adapt Colt's
TensorFlow model
to adjust those baseline
care instructions based
on each plant's health readings.
Now, Colt's model is
static, though, so we'll
collect all of this
water in Bquery
and use it to train new and
more powerful models over time.
Now the Google Tasks API--
I'm not sure why Colt
missed it, but I'll
use it here to handle all
the gardening work that
can't be handled automatically.
Pruning trees, raking leaves,
it all goes into the task list.
The task is synced
on your Android app,
and you can check them
off as they're done.
We use the app to replace Colt's
web-based status [INAUDIBLE]
and use Firebase cloud messaging
to keep it all up to date.
Then we can finish off by
using Data Studio to visualize
our garden stats and add Google
Assistant actions to allow us
voice controls for local
updates and overrides.
COLT MCANLIS: Not bad, not bad.
I mean, not good, but not bad.
RETO MEIER: Now you've
seen both of our pitches--
Colt's utilitarian farmer's
plant box, and my response,
a peaceful garden
where you're freed
from the manual burdens
of garden maintenance
to relax and enjoy nature.
COLT MCANLIS: Now here's
the really important part--
you decide which of our builds
is better by leaving comments
below the video.
RETO MEIER: And don't forget
to check out our companion
podcast, "Build Out Rewound,"
also linked in the description
below, where we'll discuss
our implementations
and explain some
of our decisions.
Thank you for watching this
episode of "Build Out."
As always, I'm Reto Meier.
COLT MCANLIS: And
I'm Colt McAnlis.
And always remember,
PerfMatters.
[MUSIC PLAYING]